Bienvenidos en cinco minutos el mundo
vive una crisis de biodiversidad de
acuerdo a la unión internacional para la
conservación de la naturaleza más de
41.000 especies de seres vivos están
amenazadas un 28% de las especies
documentadas hasta el momento América
Latina y el Caribe es la región con más
biodiversidad en el mundo con el 60% de
todo el planeta según Naciones Unidas
Pero también es una de las que más
perdidas de especies está experimentando
en este episodio en cinco minutos les
contamos la situación de diez especies
amenazadas en las Américas la vaquita
marina es una especie de cetáceo la más
pequeña de este tipo de mamíferos es
endémica de México en Baja California de
acuerdo a un estudio de la Universidad
de California se estima que en la
actualidad existen unas 10 vaquitas
marinas la alta disminución de sus
ejemplares se debe a la casa de estos
animales actualmente prohibida en México
al tratarse de un depredador su
presencia en el ecosistema es altamente
importante el lobo rojo es el lobo con
mayor peligro de extinción en el mundo
actualmente según erfc.org solamente
quedan unos 15 a 17 ejemplares en
libertad y otros 240 viven en monitoreo
alcanzó a ser común en el sur y este de
Estados Unidos ahora los pocos que
quedan se encuentran en Carolina del
Norte la casa de la expansión de las
ciudades así como atropellos en
carreteras han mermado a mínimos la
especie La pantera de Florida de este
gato montés solamente quedan unos 100 a
180 individuos en el pasado habitaron
todo el suroeste de Estados Unidos y
ahora solo viven como su nombre lo
indica en áreas de Florida la
construcción y la organización con la
creación de cascos urbanos carreteras y
autopistas menguaron su población el
manatí del Caribe se calcula que quedan
alrededor de unos 2500 ejemplares de
esta especie que como su nombre lo
indica en aguas del Caribe Aunque
actualmente está protegido en muchos
países fue altamente casado en décadas
anteriores lo que menguó su población en
la actualidad otros impactos humanos
como la contaminación en el mar o el
impacto contra vehículos acuáticos como
motos marinas y barcos están entre las
principales causas de su muerte el
colibrí de Juan Fernández Esta vez se
encuentra en peligro debido
principalmente a la llegada de especies
exóticas invasoras que han restringido
su acceso a la alimentación o que
depredan su hábitat el archipiélago de
Juan Fernández en Chile desde el año
2002 ongs nacionales e internacionales
trabajan tanto en su preservación como
en la de otras aves nativas del
archipiélago tortugas de Carey se estima
que su población está entre las 20.000 y
23.000 unidades en los últimos 30 años
sus poblaciones han disminuido en un
80%. las principales causas de que la
especie se peligro son la casa y la
distribución de los caparazones y
productos de Carey afectaciones a su
hábitat como los arrecifes de coral y
sus espacios de anidación también se ven
afectadas por la contaminación y el
calentamiento de las aguas su situación
se considera en estado crítico coral de
cuernos de alce desde la década de 1980
las poblaciones de coral de cuerno de
alce han disminuido rápidamente
Aproximadamente en un
97%. antaño Era uno de los principales
formadores de corales en el Caribe ahora
está catalogado como en peligro crítico
por la unión internacional para la
preservación de la naturaleza rana del
pehuenche esta catalogada como en
peligro crítico es endémica de los
límites fronterizos entre Argentina y
chile este anfibio está amenazado por la
implantación por parte de los humanos de
truchas en los ríos de la región
principalmente por motivos deportivos al
tratar de fuertes depredadores las
truchas están acabando con estas ranas
armadillo la población de Armadillos ha
descendido notoriamente en todos los
países de los que son nativos entre las
principales causas están en la casa y la
venta ilegal de estos animales pero
también la destrucción de su hábitat
natural por la Urbanización y la
ganadería oso de anteojos es la única
especie de osos que habitan en
Sudamérica actualmente quedan unos
18.000 ejemplares de este mamífero los
cambios ambientales que está
experimentando su hábitat y las
consecuencias en la fauna y la flora lo
sitúan entre las especies más
vulnerables en la conferencia sobre la
diversidad biológica de la ONU cerca de
200 países buscan encontrar anualmente
recursos y llegar a acuerdos para
proteger las especies en peligro en los
últimos años la ONU ha pedido
reiteradamente hacer del cuidado de la
biodiversidad una acción impostergable
la biodiversidad influye en casi los
aspectos de la vida humana desde la
seguridad alimentaria hasta la creación
de antídotos y medicinas además la
preservación de las especies es vital
para conservar los ecosistemas de todo
el mundo ya que la pérdida de una
especie afecta al resto de su cadena
alimentaria y Por ende al ecosistema al
que pertenecen y ecosistemas como las
selvas tropicales o los manglares son
básicos en la absorción de gases de
efecto invernadero y Por ende en la
lucha contra el cambio climático que
amenaza el futuro del planeta si le
sirvió el vídeo para entender la
situación que afrontan algunas de las
especies de seres vivos más vulnerables
en las Américas los esperamos en otro
episodio de en cinco minutos en France
24 y France 24.com